Mesdames, s'il vous plaît, dites-moi si vous avez entendu
cela avant ce son qui
ressemble à quelque chose comme ça, vous marchez juste
sur le chemin du travail, quel que soit le gars en
arrière-plan, peut-être que vous êtes confus et que
vous ne savez pas comment classer une femme qui
parlera  son esprit n'aura pas peur
de se tromper
n'aura pas peur d'occuper l'espace n'aura
pas peur d'exprimer son opinion et
bien sûr je veux dire si ça se passe au
Canada bien sûr ça se passe
en Inde j'ai fait venir un monsieur vers moi
après et  dites que vous savez que c'était
vraiment drôle et quel excellent travail vous avez
fait, mais écoutez, vous savez, est-ce
que vos parents savent
que vous faites cela et si c'est le cas, ont-ils l'
intention de vous trouver un gars sympa et  J'ai
juste été surpris et cela m'a fait réaliser
que le genre de choses que vous
pouvez dire et les choses qui sont
acceptables dans la bouche d'une femme sont très
différentes tout d'abord de la bouche d'un homme,
vous savez, il y a ce cliché,
il y a un stéarate notre  communauté féminine
où elle parlera des périodes oh mon
dieu j'espère que pour les 20 prochaines générations
de comédiens de stand-up qui sont des femmes, nous
parlons des périodes, nous parlons du cancer du
sein parce que ces choses ne sont pas
assez et dont on parle dans
la comédie grand public, vous savez que cela met en évidence
certaines des choses les plus horribles à propos du
silence autour de choses comme les
serviettes hygiéniques l'utilisation de sable vous savez l'
hygiène menstruelle en général je suis le
genre de conséquences que cela a le genre de
je veux dire les taux de mortalité infantile les taux de
mortalité maternelle en
Inde sont  quelque chose qui est en quelque sorte
une préoccupation internationale,
c'est juste plus proche et plus facile de
chez soi quand c'est fait à travers la comédie et
quand c'est encore et encore fait à travers une voix
qui est aussi authentique que possible
[Rires]
vous ne réalisez pas seulement que les choses les plus drôles
sont parfois  les choses les plus vraies
et donc ça ne commence jamais avec une intention
de oh laissez-moi éduquer le public s'il vous plaît le
public va à l'école pour l'éducation
ils viennent se lever  la comédie pour rire
et pour moi l'objectif a toujours été
de rire d'abord et si ça fait
réfléchir les gens après ça
quand on parle de choses aussi
sensibles et bien sûr en mentionnant le
mot lu mais pourquoi évoquerais-tu dans
une émission comique et  des trucs que je suis si
ça se passe je veux en parler
c'est drôle parce que tous les Godman ont
rampé hors de la Woodworks pour donner
leur avis sur ce qu'elle aurait pu
faire pour empêcher l'attaque contre elle je suis
censé condamner les agresseurs et donc l'
un d'eux  a dit que les viols se produisent
parce que l'or a des déclarations parce que les
mots sont trop sur leurs téléphones portables
et c'est pourquoi ils sont lus
longtemps et j'ai dit bien vous savez en
fait je pense que cela aide en quelque sorte à l'
absurdité des choses qui sont
dit en ce moment ou en ce qui concerne le rôle
des femmes dans la société indienne dans juste
IAP, elles aiment beaucoup de ces punchlines que
nous n'avons pas à aimer voir ce ne sont que
des gros titres de l'actualité ce qui se passe juste quand
son tig vaginal  la crème htening continue de
déteindre sur son pénis et sa
crème d'agrandissement du pénis ne garde pas en fait je l'
ai fait et ce n'était pas très loin de vous c'était en
fait un donneur je vous donnerai à 15
minutes de chez moi tous ceux
qui sont dans la foule et hors de la  montrez à ce
monsieur des caïmans vous connaissez le solide Vinny
vous voyez tous ces trucs devant ma
femme et j'étais comme oh attendez j'ai offensé
et je pense qu'il était assez ivre ce qui est
encore une fois l'un des avantages du travail est
que vous devez être avec  un groupe de
mecs ivres ce qui donnerait droit à une mauvaise
compréhension et il a essayé de cracher
heureusement heureusement, il était assez ivre pour que
je pense que nous le reconstruisons dans ma [ __ ] pour
vraiment le projeter mais il a activement
perdu dans la cabine de projection alors vous avez vu
et puis  ça s'est juste répandu partout, il
tremble et j'étais comme eh
bien alors désolé tu penses comme si
ce n'est pas je veux dire ce n'est pas bon au moins
quel que soit le public auquel tu parles où que
tu ailles ce n'est pas sans risque